>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Tips and Tricks
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover tips and
tricks for using the software.
Help pages are available
for each screen.
Press F1 from the screen
to access its help page.
If you are using BARD
Express with a screen reader,
virtually all of the functions of
the software, including searching,
browsing, downloading, and copying
can be executed using hot keys.
Refer to the help pages for details.
Low-vision users can adjust the
font size using the View menu.
Select Font Size Larger
up to four times
until you reach the
desired font size.
BARD Express allows you
to customize the types
of information displayed
in any list of titles.
Access a book list from any
of the browse or list options.
After the titles load, use the hot
key Alt+V to access the view menu.
Select Column Configuration
from the view menu.
A dialog box containing a list
of the column headings will open.
The information categories are
type-which is book or magazine,
title, author, subject, annotation,
narrator, series, reading time,
file size, and BARD
ID-which is the book number.
Check the box associated with the
information you want displayed
for each title.
This feature may be useful if you
have several books on a cartridge
and limited space, you can
choose titles based on file size
or if you are browsing
the Recently Added Books
and Magazines list you can
quickly distinguish between books
and magazines in the list.
One last trick with BARD Express
is to access all the books
by a single author or all
the books in a single series
through the book details screen.
For example I am going to access
the book details of Kill Switch:
A Joe Ledger novel from the Recently
Added Books and Magazines list.
On this screen both the author's
name and the series title are links.
By selecting the link Joe Ledger
Novel I can access all the books
available on BARD in this series.
By selecting the link
Maberry, Jonathan,
I can access all the books
available on BARD by this author.
For more information on
transferring books, searching BARD,
and managing your wish list see
the other tutorials in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.